trying to eat the quran
no one can claim something what the
quran is claiming with all the other
additional evidences
for it to be coming from the creator
himself how would you respond if someone
says well look for our day and time
right now this is really subjective
we're going to be discussing something
that's very important because it's the
core
it's the foundation of a believer's life
it is the quran sent for all of humanity
for everyone for president trump for the
president of india for the president of
every country
from everybody in the world and the last
the last the final messenger sent to
mankind prophet muhammed peace and
blessings upon him
he's the one that was blessed with the
quran temper-free tampered proof
and we know that almost 2 billion people
because of
this quran have accepted islam we have
people from all
races nationalities backgrounds the
crown is being recited
at this very time all over the world
at different places and times we know
that the quran is the most widely read
book in the world but arguably the most
misunderstood and misrepresented
so right now in this episode we're going
to go ahead
and try to clear up the misconceptions
and represent it in a humble
attempt so you can have a clearer and
better understanding of the verbatim
word of god almighty
the quran and here with me to help me
with that
is my good friend dr sabil ahmed how are
you doing salaam alaikum
brother eddie and everyone alhamdulillah
it's so good to see you
you're going to help me to tackle
somebody i have some very important
questions
regarding the quran and inshallah you
can help me to cover these how's that
sound
alhamdulillah let's proceed because as
you know and i know
you got people who are talking about the
quran
they're not sincerely reading it to try
to understand it
and then you also have a lot of doubt
that's being created out there by the
satanic forces
you got all sorts of cr people you got
even people have you seen that lately
trying to eat the quran
have you seen that one
i have not seen it but i would not be
surprised you know people do all crazy
things
uh may allah give them hidayah i mean
and that's why we're doing this episode
so we can help clear up some of the
misconceptions
and give also muslims who live by a
strong footing to be upon it
so tell me dr sabil we know that people
write books
all the time but this quran
many people look at it just some book
that maybe muhammad wrote
salah-salam or another group of people
but how could we be sure
that the quran is indeed from allah does
it say it is
as we speak on this topic first and
foremost we have to thank allah for
honoring us
and giving us this opportunity so we are
learning the deen
in sha allah with allah's help
practicing the deen and sharing the deen
so that's an honor that allah gave to
the previous prophets and the messengers
and that honor is now given to the
muslim ummah so we should be ever
thankful to allah for this opportunity
when it comes to the quran it's
important that previous prophets and the
messengers they were given
certain miracles those miracles were
limited to their time
and to their people so they were
time-bound
and they were people bound for example
the miracle given to
prophet uh jesus peace be upon him and
his mother mariam peace be upon her
that she was a virgin and he was born to
a virgin mother and he spoke
in the cradle that was a miracle we
cannot see it now
it is only we can we can read it in the
quran
moses prophet moses moosa peace be upon
him
he was given the miracle many miracles
spotting the red sea for example is one
nual he was saved from the flood
ibrahimo salaam you know safe from the
fire and the sacrifices of his son
are about to be sacrificed uh yunus
salaam right say from the
from the fish from the whale
miracles so there are many miracles
given to previous prophets and the
messengers
and these are signs from allah just to
remind people that these individuals are
special they are humans they are special
they are prophets believing their
message
so all of these miracles in the past
that allah has given yes we believe in
it
however the miracle that was given to
prophet muhammad peace be upon him is
the ultimate miracle
he said is the miracle of the miracles
so what are some of the miracles within
the miracle of the quran
what are some of the ways we can
enlighten our fellow americans and
people of humanity
so first and foremost the quran itself
says it is from allah
many many places one of those places in
surah sajdah surah 32 ayah number two
that allah says here is the translation
that
the revelation of this quran is from the
lord of the alamin
it's from allah so the book itself says
that
the author's name is there that the
author is
the almighty creator allah
but however brother eddie i mean you may
have read
you know for the sake of research i have
done it old testament new testament
the hindu vedas the sikh scriptures you
know the buddhist scriptures i have read
them
i have not seen anywhere in the new
testament for example
that this book or the new testament or
any book of the new testament
is coming from a revelation or
inspiration from allah
or from god of the new testament quran
mentions it
other scriptures they're not as adamant
they're not as clear
so that itself is an is an indication
that the author is mentioning
that he is the one who composed it not
muhammad peace be upon him or any other
creation now if you contrast that with
the bible or any other book
so you're saying that in the quran we
have it where god almighty
the author of the quran allah he is
identifying himself
as the author now if we contrast that
with other books
that claim do they make they do they
even make the claim that they're from
the creator that people
impose on others and say no this is from
god
in the old testament yes there are
references that you know
ten commandments are coming from the god
of the bible
isaiah received inspiration right and so
there are indications in the old
testament however in the new testament
all the 27 books of the new testament
from the book of matthew mark luke john
all the way to revelation
not a single place the god of the bible
says that
these books are coming from god
quran makes it no book of the new
testament
makes that claim so that's a really good
important indication it's not the only
uh
evidence there are many evidences but at
least the author of the quran says it is
from him
you mentioned the old testament does it
say actually in the old testament
that god almighty is saying i revealed
this
book like the quran says that i have
indeed revealed that i will
preserve it do we have such a statement
in any other book like you have in the
quran
no not the way that we have in the quran
in
hinduism
there is no statement like that in any
book
yes not even the old testament so
quran is unique to that aspect that
allah is saying he is the one who
has sent it and allah is saying that he
is the one who is going to preserve it
no direct statement no statement to that
with that kind of assurance and
authority that this is the book
directly coming from allah and this is
the book he will take the authority
to preserve it masha'allah quranic quran
is unique in that aspect
before i go to the next question i just
want us to really ponder and reflect
and give another example to this because
this is very powerful
just like how would you paint this
picture dr sebio
if someone you have a lot of money for
example and you want to guard your money
right
because people are going to be after
that money but then you take it to a
particular
safety deposit box or somewhere where
they have the top line security and
they're just like
don't worry trust us your money is going
to be safe here
and then you they can show you the whole
security system and everything you can
go home
and sleep well at night knowing that
your money's protected right
but that's the security come we're
talking about here the creator of the
heavens and the earth i mean have we
wrapped our mind around that that he is
the one who revealed he's saying i will
protect it
there is nothing that no one can do to
tamper with this book
to change it like the previous
scriptures were changed
this is deep isn't it alhamdulillah
but brother eddie there may be an
objection to this argument of ours this
evidence of ours
what's that objection now yeah the
objection is that
you know in my presentations perhaps in
your interactions with
the christians the non-muslims they may
say you know what anyone can write a
book and they say that this book is
coming from god it doesn't make it so
that true brother eddie yeah how do you
differentiate that now someone's saying
okay
someone writing a book and just saying
okay putting in those words that okay
this is from god and
and from a outside standpoint they're
saying like anybody can do that how
would you answer that
right so that's a valid objection so
what we can say as muslims
is that yes anyone can write a book and
ascribe that to god
however there are other evidences for
the truth of the quran but at least they
should acknowledge and they should
realize
that the author's name and the author's
authority is there in the quran
unlike other books the way that we have
mentioned
so at least that aspect is there the
author is saying that it is not muhammad
peace be upon him
it is not any arab or the greek the
persians the romans egyptians
it is the creator himself who composed
and revealed and benefit the humanity
with this quran
this is amazing have you come across
anything in your studies
over all these years being involved in
dawah sharing this message
have you ever come across something like
this where
since we raised someone raised that
objection i haven't where you have a
book i mean
people make all sorts of claims but even
in this area
i haven't seen something stand the test
and someone come out to write a book
like that and say okay
this is from god and then to to this day
it's gained
close to 2 billion followers that's just
living today we're not calculating
everybody from the time of prophet
muhammad
who has continued to recite and preserve
this book memorize this and then go over
all the
other things that we're going to go over
have you come across anything even close
to that
brother eddie there there have been many
many false prophets for example
you know when you look at the religion
of baha'ism they may claim that what
baha'u'llah may have written is also
divine and they may have so many
followers
i mean not obviously two billion
followers or you may have
what he rose what he composed their
followers may claim that likewise
he was receiving revelation uh you know
buddhists may claim something similar
sikhs may claim something similar
but no one can claim something what the
quran is claiming with all the other
additional evidences
for it to be coming from the creator
himself
let's move on to challenges is there
anything else that someone can look at
and say is there
a challenge now in the quran that god
almighty
says if you do such such and such action
you can go ahead and disprove or prove
the quran
you know there are many alhamdulillah
there are many falsification tests
that allah itself is making just to make
the non-muslims realize
that this quran is special but before we
mention that it's
important to look at the context in
which these
these falsification tests and these
challenges came
in arabic language in the 7th century
was at its pinnacle that means
people at that time they were masters of
the arabic language
you know we say that in the english
language there was one shakespeare
in the arabic language in the seventh
century there were many many
shakespeares roaming around
every block every city every town they
used to have competitions
who is the best in poetry and in prose
they used to have prizes
in that context in those times allah
subhanahu ta'ala made these eternal
challenges
as our brother has recited eloquently
masha'allah
so the very first challenge came in
surah al israel 17 ayah number 88
that the translation if all of humanity
and
all of jinns can come together to
produce the likeness of the quran they
would never be able to do it
even if they come together for help and
support now it's important the arabs of
that time
they rejected the quran i mean most of
them right some of them they embraced it
they rejected the quran initially
because they were thinking this quran is
coming from muhammad peace be upon him
or somebody was teaching him
or he copied from somewhere else
so they were taking away the divine
nature of the quran and giving it
a creation you know composition of the
quran
so allah subhanahu wa is saying that if
you believe that this is coming from a
person
why don't you compose something like
this i mean you are masters of your
language
not just one person just all of you
together
not just the arabs all of mankind
together not just mankind
you can throw in the jins in there and
not just that
it's not limited to only for those
people in that time
it is an eternal challenge until the end
of time
but the idea not just that you know now
we have
these super computers you know like 10
years ago
maybe the time has changed now 10 years
ago when i did the research on this
topic i found out
that they are super computers that that
can calculate
like billions of calculations in a
second
so we can put in all the arabic
dictionaries in there
all the you know classical and
pre-quranic
and post-quranic uh poetry and prose all
the arabic books
and the dictionaries in the world
combined in that
supercomputer so what allah is saying
that
all of that knowledge all humans and
jinns coming together
could never produce the likeness of the
quran
the way the quran has been you know the
choice of words it
it uses the multiple layers the
eloquency the benefits scientific facts
solutions all of them combined no human
can produce it no one can produce it
so that is the first challenge the
second challenge came in surah hud
ayah number 13. fine cannot produce one
whole book produce and at least 10
surahs like the quran
then the last challenge came in surah
baqarah ayah number 23
that to produce some
to produce somewhat like one surah like
the quran
now it's important for us to know that
the arabs
who rejected the quran they were bent on
destroying
islam all they had to do was
come together and sit together
with their scholars and produce one
surah like the quran
brother eddie what is mind boggling
about this challenge is
allah subhanahu talaha in surah baqarah
is not saying that produce something
like the largest surah of the quran
and you know and i know right it is
surah baqarah it has 286
ayaats and verses in there allah
subhanahu ta'ala is saying that
you can produce like any surah like the
quran
and the smaller surah of the quran only
has three ayahs in it
and has only 10 verses in it
so this is a challenge which is eternal
all they had to do was come together if
they wanted to dismantle islam but they
could not
when they heard the quran when they saw
the prophet recited
they were just speechless so in their
hatred and arrogance
instead of coming together
intellectually
defeating islam in the quran they fought
about 27 wars and battles with the
prophet
peace be upon him
so this itself is an indication and a in
a strong evidence
that the quran is from allah there is a
creator and islam is true
how would you respond and someone says
well look for our day and time right now
this is really subjective
right how how would you answer this
right so this is a common objection that
people may have in our open houses when
we have
interactions with non-muslims dhawa boos
people raise this objection you know
what this is a
subjective challenge let's suppose for
example brother eddie
i'm not sure have you eaten biryani any
time
yes oh you did ok spicy right for you
perhaps
suppose if you're the judge and if you
give a challenge to all the participants
over here
okay fine all of you you cook biryani
and
i'm going to invite you will say i'm
going to invite five judges
to see that whose biryani is going to
taste the best
now if me and brother ejaz and all of us
we cook biryani
and the five judges they may be thinking
you know what this is a subjective test
this is based upon the taste of a person
so that is an example of something which
is subjective
evaluation but the quranic challenge is
not subjective because and here is the
reason what the scholars say
first and foremost they say that
anything a person compose
composes in the arabic language
it can fall into one of the three
categories
in the category of bihar which is the
poetry or in the category of prose
or a category which is the combination
of prose and poetry
and the in the poetry itself in the
arabic language has about 16 categories
so anything anyone composes has to fall
in one of the three categories
of arabic composition
it so happened whether eddie you'll be
surprised to find out
that when the arabs when they saw or
when they heard when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
was reciting the quran it did not fell
into any one of these categories
yes it has some uh you know highlights
from three of them but they did not
clearly fell into any one of these three
categories
you know it's just like uh an analogy
can be like a competition
suppose if there is a competition of the
designers and the engineers
and they were told to design a you know
a high-rise building for example
they may come and they may design and
then they may construct
maybe high buildings maybe beautifully
looking buildings maybe this design that
design
but at the end of the day all of them
would be three dimensional
anything that they are going to design
however if some is someone is going to
design age sculpture
in real life using the same material and
that would be
five-dimensional all the engineers would
be baffled speechless
how can somebody design like that with
the current knowledge and technology
and that is the analogy of the quran and
loose analogy i would say
that quran is a multi-dimensional
outside of the three dimensions
of the arabic language and that's what
make them speechless
that's what make them arrogant and
that's the reason they came
to fight islam not intellectually
but physically so yes brother eddie
it is not a subjective challenge it is
an objective challenge
is that it has to be in arabic language
it cannot be just you know some words
put together without any meaning
it has to be at least three verses long
it has to have at least
uh you know ten uh ten
words in there it cannot be the speech
of a soothsayer
it cannot be poetry it cannot be just
plain prose
it has to have deep meaning it has to
have all of these facts and solutions
all of them combined together it makes a
challenge
as objective and not subjective
dr sabile now we covered the first point
which was very important and we're going
to continue
on with many of these other points but
what i want to know is
from the authorship of the quran you
cover that beautifully
we know that the quran on every page of
the quran you have god almighty allah
his name is mentioned his attributes are
mentioned on every page of the quran
you talked about now the challenge here
that if you do such and such that's that
falsification test
you discuss that we'll go on to point
number three but before
i want to just touch upon the part two
the challenge it's it's amazing you know
that there was one individual
he was the last and final messengers
prophet muhammad's
uncle that the quran talks about him
that he's going to be in the hell fire
isn't that amazing i always think about
this
that all he had to do so you're painting
a scenario that while the revelation is
being revealed
you have a staunch enemy to the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
his uncle
one was actually helping him the other
one was trying to hurt him
and he was doing some very vile and
degenerate things
and he was an enemy to islam and then
allah reveals in the quran that he
is going to be in the hell fire so
i mean all he had to do was to just
prove the quran
was to do what dr sabil is to just
pretend
that he has recited the shahadah and has
become a muslim
and he can just you know go and ridicule
the muslims you know what your quran is
saying there's a prophecy in there in
surabullah
that i'm going to be in the hell fire
but here look
i have become a muslim what do you say
now muslims would be in an awkward
position
prophet perhaps would be in an awkward
position he never did that he had
years and years to listen to their surah
and live with their surah but never came
forward
even to just to become a fake muslim
that's amazing isn't it amazing
masha'allah right i mean
one of the elites of the quraysh the
leaders of arabia
all right so let's move on to what we
also know to be
something that's another amazing miracle
of the quran
that if you were to take all of the
books
that people go by
as a religious text as just a general
text
of something that you might have picked
up at barnes and noble whatever the case
and they were to take all these books
and lock them up in a safe
or throw them in the oceans to get rid
of them is this a fact that
you would not be able to if there was no
copies made
and you had to bring these books back
and the author wasn't around
how would you bring these books back
like the quran and that's what we talk
about the
preservation of the quran that the quran
is this a fact that it would be the only
book
out of all these books that you
destroyed that you would be able to
bring
back because of the preservation miracle
of the quran
alhamdulillah i know that itself during
my interactions brother eddie
perhaps open houses or one to one with
our
non-muslim brothers and sisters there's
when people ask about the quran there
are many many evidences that we can give
if i have only just a short time i only
give this one evidence
and that is the preservation of the
quran and i give them certain context to
it
you know they may claim they may say
obviously they are
they are wrong that your prophet wrote
the quran right that's what they say
maybe he copied from the bible and what
not i mentioned to them
it is a really risky for any person to
make prophecies
it's really risky for any false prophet
to make a prophecy because
if the prophecy comes to be false the
person is taken out
and be you know taken out from being a
prophet
what he's claiming to be as so it's
risky to make prophecies however there
are many many prophecies in the quran
the foremost amongst them in surah
al-hijjah ayah number nine surah 15 ayah
number nine
in which allah says
it is allah who has revealed this zikr
this message this revelation it is allah
who will protect it
now a false prophet in his time
could keep the manuscript of the quran
like in bank of america for example
right or the swiss bank or any bank and
surrounded by soldiers
but what is the guarantee brother eddie
of that prophecy to be fulfilled
after that person is gone after a few
generation who is going to protect the
quran or that manuscript of that person
but we have seen alhamdulillah from the
time of muhammad peace be upon him
up until our time and this will continue
until the end of time
allah promised the quran would be
preserved and we can see the
manifestation
that muhammad peace be upon him by the
miracle of allah he became the very
first
you know hafiz of the quran memorize the
whole quran so refatiha the surah
some of his companies they memorized it
both the male and the female companions
and they passed it down from their time
to our time multiple
chains of memorizers many many hundreds
of schools
all over the world they were teaching
and they were sharing
and they were they are like multiple
checks and balances
if this one person makes a mistake in
recitation
multi people people around him they may
correct it in this way the quran
came down to us and the the number which
i gave
now for our time 21st century 2020
is that they are no less than 10 million
hoffas
memorizers of the complete quran in the
arabic language
in the arabic right not in king james
english not in spanish
not in urdu hindi in in the arabic
language
and brother eddie even mind-boggling
that then
this fact is when you look just into
christianity right just into the new
testament
you know there are 1.1 billion catholics
around the world about 900 million
protestants around the world
there are about 5100 bishops around the
world right and these are like the
shaykhs of the
catholics uh 409 000 plus
priest of the catholic faith and then
you have the pope
right he's like the khalifa for them
none of them brother eddie memorized the
entire
bible not even the new testament which
is the second half of the bible
even if somebody comes to me and say you
know sabil
i memorize the bible the new testament i
will ask the person
hey which version of the bible have you
memorized i don't want the king james
virgin which is just a translation
have you memorized the bible in the
ancient hebrew or the classical aramaic
language
not in greek not in english or spanish
but in the actual language of prophet
jesus peace be upon him the aramaic
language
not a single person brother eddie zero
not even the pope
have memorized the entire new testament
forget about the whole bible
and that is a miracle only islam can
claim and the quran can claim
alhamdulillah
have you heard any objections what's the
top objection to this
that we just discussed the preservation
of the quran yeah
one objection that people so as i was
traveling from chicago to houston
i was mentioning the same evidence so
many of my dhafa
interactions happen in the plane because
of traveling
a brother next to me a non-muslim
brother next to me when i mention this
important
uh evidence of the quran he mentioned
that you know what
hey sabil is that not like a game of
telephone
for those of our brothers and sisters in
india if you're not aware
there's a game of telephone that they
play in the u.s perhaps in europe too
in which people sit around in the circle
and one person says something like in
the year of the next person
and that person is supposed to now
convey that
to the person next to him and the person
next to him it comes back
in a circle to the very first person and
the very first person now
calls it out loud what he heard from the
person who is on the left to him
and almost always what he said initially
is different than what he heard from
this person right
so they say is that not like the game of
telephone
and i said to them it's not like the
game of telephone because
by the eddie if i'm saying something to
the person on my right
before the person on the right mentions
it to the person on his right he has to
make sure
that what he heard is indeed correct if
he makes a mistake the person on the
of left who conveyed to him will correct
him
or many people will correct him and the
person to next to him before he says
something what he heard
if he makes any mistake everyone will
correct him right
so in that way no person is going to
convey other than what was originally
heard from the very first person
and what was what is is going to come
back will exactly what will be conveyed
from the very first person
so it's not like the game of telephone
because there are checks and balances
both
within the fast and between the fast who
are the memorizers
and the manuscripts of the quran which
goes back to the very first century
all right so we covered three very
important points here
does the quran say it's from god
almighty the creator of law
we answer that question indeed it does
we talked about the challenge the
falsification test
point number two preservation of this
book the quran like no other book we
just covered that let's
give him a few more points to ponder and
think
but the formula is that a person has to
be sincere
not disingenuous but generally seeking
to know the truth
to know why they've been created in the
quran is a blueprint for life to give
the human being everything they need to
be successful in this life in the next
but now we're clearing up those doubts
and help that jakeen that certainty also
for those who have kind of gotten weak
in their iman so let's go ahead now from
here
talk about we know a person can go ahead
and talk
one way one day and then
contradict himself the next day do we
find anything like that
in the quran such as contradictions
because if you find one contradiction
it can't be from the creator of the
heavens and earth
but the eddie just like we have
falsification tests when it comes to
challenges and other evidences of the
quran
here is one more falsification test but
allah is saying
in surah 4 chapter number 4 verse number
82
translation is don't they ponder over
the quran
had it been from anyone besides allah
you would have found
in many contradictions in it
allah is giving a falsification test
that if you find contradictions in it
it cannot be from allah so
it's a mind-boggling brother eddie it's
not just about instructions in the quran
you know the do's and the don'ts the
guidance
yes that is there along with that the
six
thousand plus ayahs are the passages
verses in the quran
they cover like a encyclopedic you know
wide range of knowledge comprehensive
they cover about people of the past
historical facts prophets of the past
it covers about scientific facts uh
quran covers about
uh you know multiple prophecies
uh instructions solutions all of them
combined together not a single mistake
no contradiction between two verses
and that is unique because you know i
know you know the christian scholars
they admit
muslim scholars they proclaim that
yes they are contradictions in the
previous scriptures
old testament verses with each other old
testament verses
with the new testament new testament
verses with each other
you know hindu veda so there are
contradictions in the scriptures
that people have written
no single contradiction both internal
contradiction within the quran or
external contradiction with facts
outside of the quran
like if the quran mentions about certain
aspect in history
there is no contradiction between what
the quran says and what historians
have verified to be as a fact or
scientist for that matter
so this is a falsification test that
itself is a strong indication
it is not from any human any creation it
is coming from the lord of the arameen
allah
have you ever come across where people
might point out
a contradiction but now
upon explaining things in context
it's not a contradiction it just took a
little bit more
of a person digging and putting things
in context
rather than with their limited
understanding trying to go ahead and
point something out that's not an
apparent that's not a contradiction have
you had some of these that someone might
read something and say okay look here's
a contradiction but actually in
actuality
it's not a contradiction all these
things uh that were
possibly some doubt that they've all
been
answered and they've been explained
fully all right so it's really important
the way that our scholars they they try
to reconcile
any supposed contradiction brought by
any person
is first and foremost they tell them you
know what first read in arabic language
not in english right not in
ancient english but in arabic number one
number two let's look at other verses of
the quran and also
the whole quran about you know the
meaning of that specific passage number
three we have to look into the
historical context
linguistic context the actual meaning
linguistically at that time
all of them combined together brother
eddie of the six thousand
plus passages of the quran zero
contradictions
and even every contradiction which some
people they bring in
they have all been dealt with you know
with authority
with uh the proper evidence from the
classical arabic within the passages of
the
they have been dealt with zero
contradictions so one example that some
people may bring in brother eddie
yes please when they look into surah
number 40 ayah number 36 to iron number
37 i will just give the translation
here there is a person called haman
mentioned in the quran in this ayahs of
the quran and haman is supposedly
a person who used to build lofty palaces
and he was supposed to be one of the
people the elite the leaders
who used to build in the time of pharaoh
the firaoun of musa al-islam
so the quran says that pharaoh is
speaking and saying that you know o
haman build for me a left a lofty palace
that i may attain the vase and the means
the ways and the means
of reaching the heavens that i may mount
up to the guard of moses but as far as
i'm concerned i think
moses is a liar nozbe so haman is
mentioned in the quran
and the same haman with the same name is
also mentioned
in the old testament in the book of
esther there haman is not
in the court of pharaoh he is in babylon
like one thousand one hundred years
after the firaoun of
uh of the quran so old testament
scholars and the new testament scholars
for many many centuries
they used to make fun of the muslims
of the quran saying you know what this
is what the bible says
quran makes a contradiction quran is
saying that haman is from
egypt but actually haman is from babylon
right
by iraq lo and behold brother eddie
about two centuries ago egyptologists
what they figured out is that they found
tablets ancient egyptian tablets in
which it is written
that haman actually belonged to egypt
there is no evidence no hardcore
evidence of haman of the old testament
but now they have scientists they have
the evidence of haman
to prove that he actually existed
in the in the time of iran in the time
of musa
so you have the biblical story and the
quranic story
and here comes science and the
archaeology is to prove that yes
the quranic story is true i mean we
don't need scientists we don't need
archaeologists and
uh you know the scholars in the ancient
uh uh you know writings
allah is enough but at least to the
people who doubt who may think there are
contradictions
alhamdulillah allah is providing for
them using even their signs to show that
quran is from allah
this is truly amazing what if somebody
says well this was just
copied from the bible from other ancient
texts
greek mythology chinese
mythology what would you say well if
someone copied from some other scripture
they would copy the same mistake you
know one other example can we fire on
the quran mentions that the body of the
firon after he was drowned
it will be preserved for as a sign for
people to come
right surah 10 surah yunus number 92.
now the similar story is mentioned in
the in the old testament in the book of
exodus
chapter 14 verse number 28 firaoun's
army everyone was engulfed with water
they all drowned end of story
the bible does not say anything more
about firaoun
quran adds something new to it now
scientist
right dr dr maurice bukai he did autopsy
on the body of iran in 1975 and he also
proclaimed
you know very similar to other
scientists that yes this is the body of
the pharaoh
who was from the time of moses because
of the
because of certain things that they have
seen when they did the autopsy
so you have the biblical story and the
quranic story and science now confirms
medical science
that the quran is story is true if it
were copied
where did where did prophet muhammad
peace be upon him had this additional
information
true information and medical information
in the quran quran is not copied it is
coming from the lord of the alameda
so many many such examples inshallah for
some future show
but at least to enlighten our non-muslim
brothers and sisters
quran is not copied it is coming from
the creator of the heavens and the earth
i mean you hear these things and this
really
you know the human being has within him
he has obviously
the fitra that gravitates towards the
truth
you have that god spot that allah put in
your brain inside of you i mean
to resonate with things that when it
comes to you
that your go towards of truth and this
is
when you keep hearing these things these
aren't where you have to take such a
like many people they have to take
what's called the leap of faith
i mean islam the quran is stimulating
you
intellectually emotionally in all these
aspects and we can see that by
many of these points and many of these
facts that you're bringing to fruition
let's couple do a couple more points
that some people they
talk about prophecies a lot you know
they mentioned for instance and people
will go ahead and mention nostradamus
for instance who
uh you've heard of nostradamus yes yes i
did but you know what that person's
prophecies are so vague
they can go either way right that's
right that's what i was going to say
exactly so that's the point i wanted to
make where people will stick to
something that's very vague
you know because when we say this point
i'm going to ask you about the
prophecies some people will think to
that and say oh this is just very
subjective and
or they'll bring up someone like oh my
nostradamus he made these prophecies too
and you know they'll try to equate that
what's the uniqueness
of the prophecies that are made by we
have ton of them by prophet muhammed
peace and muslim upon but in the quran
right so really quickly about
nostradamus right it's important
that many westerners know about him
books are written about him movies and
documentaries
and why not of the quran how come the
quran is not as much popular within the
non-muslim population
it is because i blame myself that i have
not done my job
muslims have not done our jobs in every
single evidence that we are providing
here by the eddie
each single one of them can it's so
profound
that it is going to pierce the hearts
and the minds and the intellect of the
individual
so we as muslims we have to step up to
the plate and fulfill our responsibility
allah will open the doors inshallah
so coming back to some other prophecies
of the quran
in surah surah 30 ayah number two to
ayah number four
allah so the historical context is that
there used to be
many many battles between the persians
who were a superpower and the romans the
byzantines who were superpowers
during one of those battles around the
year 614 the persians
utterly routed the byzantine empire
they were at the brink of collapse at
that time
allah subhanahu ta'ala he makes a
prophecy which is in the quran
that the romans have been defeated
but within a short time right in the
arabic it says about maybe three to nine
years
within that time the romans will come
back and they will defeat the persians
on that day the muslims are going to
rejoice and this is going to have
and this battle is going to have in the
lowest land
so there are three pro there are two
prophecies and one scientific fact in
there
so by the year 623 that's where
a battle happened between the romans and
the persians
and in that battle brother eddie low and
behold even though the byzantine empire
were at the brink of extinction
no person person of sanity is going to
put his worth
on the byzantine empire that they are
going to come back and win but lo and
behold that's what happened
prophecy number one is fulfilled
prophecy number two in there is that
muslims are going to rejoice yes muslims
were rejoicing because the christians
were winning
they were also rejoicing because the
muslims were winning against the pagans
against the mushrikeen of the makkah
in the battle of badr right second
prophecy fulfilled
in those four ayahs the third prophecy
or the scientific fact in there is that
that battle between the persians
and the byzantines that is going to
happen in the lowest land
in fact the lowest land
of anywhere in the whole world the land
which is the lowest when it comes to the
sea level
it is the land by the dead sea
and that land is about 509 miles
before below sea meters not miles below
sea level
i have been there by the eddy right it's
so congested humid and what i
have been there there is the lowest land
that's where the prophecy happened
that's where the battle happened at that
time there were no
you know google satellite imaging right
scientific instruments
to let anyone know that is the lowest
land the quran says it that's where the
battle happened
two prophecies fulfilled so this is just
one indication again
that the quran has prophecies it's risky
for any person to make prophecies
quran makes prophecies and every single
one of them they have been fulfilled
in the way that they are proclaimed in
the quran
indicating again that this is a miracle
coming only from the lord of the arabin
we got another point i want to go over
that i think is important
as many of these are because we live in
a day and time of science i mean the
book is
the quran is not a book of science but
signs there are signs in there
are there any of these signs now that
are in the quran
that correlate but with science but we
know that science
is something that can change but is
there something that
you'd like to point out that's
verifiable empirical that you can look
at
and use as an evidence for the quran
yes brother eddie you know many scholars
many scientists
people of you know specializing in
different fields muslims non-muslim
when they looked into the quran they
found out you know the quran has 6000
plus
uh passages in there no less than 500
plus of them brother eddie speaks about
modern science scientific facts facts of
you know physics and chemistry
biochemistry
uh plate tectonics cosmology you know
embryology
anatomy physiology yes these are
scientific facts really quickly i wish
we had a whole episode maybe some other
time
allah to enlighten the non-muslims
especially the atheists he's saying
in surah number uh
in chapter number 21 verse number 30 the
translation is
don't the unbeliever say that the
heavens and the earth they were joined
together like one primordial mass
it is allah who has sent it asunder i
mean there was a big split in there
so if we ask any cosmologists how did
the universe began they would say
13.8 billion years ago everything was
combined together
all the galaxies the planets solar
system starts together
infinitely small you know primordial
mass from there there was a big
explosion
and then from there all the stars
galaxies everything that we see they
were formed
allah is alluding to it chapter 21 verse
number 30.
in chapter number 21 verse number 33
again allah is saying
the the sun the moon and all the
celestial bodies
they are rotating and they are evolving
again this is a modern scientific fact
when it comes to embryology chapter 21
verse number chapter 23 verse number 12
13 and 14
it describes the stages from the time of
fertilization
up until the later stages of an embryo
how it develops so many scientists by
the eddy they came
and they studied the quran even the
non-muslims one of them is dr keith
moore have you heard his name
yes dr keith moore so when i was in
medical school one of the books that we
have to study was his book
dr keith moore so he wrote a book on him
rheology he won
first prize for his book in embryology
way back in the 80s
and in his book in his book he wrote
down
and he also made the statement on the
camera
that he said that for the past three
years
dr keith moore is saying right a
non-muslim christian embryologist
i have studied i have worked with
embryology committee
of saudi arabia helping them interpret
the many statements in the quran and
hadith
referring to human reproduction and
prenatal development
and he's saying at first i was
astonished
at the accuracy of the statements that
were recorded in the 7th century 80
before the science of embryology was
established and then he concludes
it had been a great it had been a great
pleasure for me to help clarify
statements in the quran about human
development it is clear to me that these
statements
must have come to muhammad peace be upon
him from god
or allah he says because most of this
knowledge was not discovered up until
many centuries later
this proves to me he's saying that
muhammad peace be upon him
must have been a messenger of god or
allah
end of quote so non-muslim embryologists
anatomies cosmologists geologists they
are coming together they are saying that
yes
and there are many many more miracles
scientific facts like this
that all of them we can say it cannot be
coincidence
you know coincidence happens once twice
maybe three times 10 times
not 500 times this is beyond the scope
of
impossible right this is in the realm of
impossible this many coincidences
even from the mathematical point of view
so this again establishes the fact
that quran cannot be from a human
compositions or else you know people
make mistakes you know galileo made
mistakes many mistakes einstein made
mistakes brother eddie do you know that
he made a blunder he used to say that
the universe is static
it's not expanding quran says it is
expanding
chapter 51 verse number 47. so even
scientists
even einstein made mistakes now they
have to come back and say you know what
i made that error
quran has 500 scientific facts zero
mistakes
cannot be from a human no technology in
that no microscope no telescope no
ultrasound no
instruments quran made those statements
cannot be the word of muhammad peace be
upon him this is the word
of allah it's a miracle brother
yeah this is amazing that these things
are lucid it's very straightforward very
clear we covered
six of those points the authorship of
the quran where god almighty
is in the quran saying stating it's from
him he'll preserve it the challenge of
the quran the preservation of the quran
the no contradiction the quran the
prophecies in the quran
the scientific facts in the quran
and then let's just add one more thing
because this is a question that every
human being should be asking him or
herself
why have i been created why am i here
what's my purpose in life
what does the quran say about this very
important
topic of purpose and does it answer that
fundamental question why have i been
created why am i here
and then give me direction on how to
achieve success in this life
and what's waiting for me in the next
life when i pass and die from this life
exactly brother eddie you know all of
these side effects facts are good to
bring a person
to look into the quran but ultimately
quran is not
a book of science a book of history a
book of prophecies yes those things are
there
as a miracle to show to the person this
book is from a divine nature
so the quran itself mentions the purpose
of life is not just to get phd degrees
and to
you know get gold medals in the olympics
or to get a good house and
you know all of these ulterior things
that we take for granted
the purpose allah mentions in the quran
chapter 51 verse number 56
is that the only reason allah created
the humans and the jinns
that they should worship me so
the quran mentions in chapter number 2
verse number 185
that in the month of ramadan the quran
was revealed as a guidance
yeah guidance for all of humanity and is
the criteria to distinguish between
right and wrong
so ultimately the reason allah has given
us this manual
for humanity is to guide humanity so we
can live
as brothers and sisters as one human
family worshiping the creator
it can transform our lives it can bring
justice unity equality solutions
to humanity and ultimately peace with
the help of
with the guidance of allah so allah
subhanahu talaha has given many
solutions in the quran brother eddie and
this is
the last of the very important evidences
of the many evidences
that quran is divine you know humanity
is struggling
about solutions to racism i mean
unfortunately
the most advanced country you know
technologically right not morally
most advanced country in the world is
usa
and they're struggling with racism every
single day
you know protests are there people are
getting shot because of color and race
and
background we are struggling we don't
have solutions
islam provided the best solution
in the quran surah ayah number 13 and
through the words the deeds the
practices
of prophet muhammad peace be upon him
racism was abolished in the seventh
century in arabia
we are struggling with it quran has
solutions
against the breakdown of the family
structure against suicides
you know homicides uh drug problem
gambling problem
any problem quran has solutions unlike
the old testament new testament
unlike the vedas and the 60 scriptures
so this is a strong indication brother
eddie that this book is divine
or else a human mind in the 7th century
could not have con
conceived comprehensive beneficial
complete and practical solutions to
human problems
not only in the 7th century but all the
way till the end of time
not just the solutions but
transformation of a person
family and society and that is a miracle
of the many many miracles of the quran
allah
alhamdulillah i want to thank you dr
sabil for going over these important
points and i think as people are talking
about the quran this should motivate
people to read the quran to look into
the quran to be
genuine not disingenuous and ask the
creator of the heavens and earth for
guidance
because we have a short amount of time
in this earth we're going to die soon
our departure date is coming
and these facts that you mentioned
should really stimulate the human being
to look more into the quran because if
you read every other book
what do you have to lose by reading the
quran sincerely
and humbly and from there you have all
your questions answered and then not
only do you save yourself you get
salvation from the hellfire
next you get the blueprint for this life
here but you also get paradise in the
next life thank you dr sabil
for covering these very important points
accepted from us the only addition thing
i would like to say is that
you know to all the muslim brothers and
sisters and those who would be listening
and who are listening outside of this
forum
you know allah has honored us and i
usually say
the reason we have islamophobia either
in india kashmir china
philosophy in us anywhere in the world
is because islamophobia is a is a
symptom
of a problem of lack of education
they are lacking education about allah's
guidance of the quran
noble example of prophet muhammad peace
be upon him
and the wonderful evidence is for
quranic truth
the reason they don't have that
knowledge is because obviously they
allah gave them a mind they have to
think and research and find out
second important reason we have not done
our job
my dear brothers my dear sisters you
know we have one life to live
let's make the most insha'allah to
become the east of islam
inviting humanity to la ilaha muhammad
rasulullah
we do our job allah will do his job
insha allah
and inshallah the same way that allah
has opened the doors in the time of the
prophets
in the time of the sahaba and later
generations
he will do the same for us but we have
to step up to the plate
i will close with this ayah of the quran
just as a reminder to myself and all of
you
sure number 124.
that you have been made an ummah justly
balanced that you become witnesses to
humanity
the way the messenger of allah is a
witness over you
and i hope and pray that may allah make
it easy
protect us the muslims in india china
palestine all over the world
unite our hearts and minds and make us
ambassadors of peace ambassadors of
islam to humanity
to all of you
[Music]
um